andrea starts off this hour in
tallahassee florida
hey andreas how are you hey how's it
going dave
better than i deserve what's up in your
world
all right so um 20 years old
and i'm graduating college in about a
year
and a graduate with no debt which is
pretty awesome good for you how'd you do
that
well i've been working jobs here and
there and also i'm
fortunate my parents have helped me very
good
so it's not ending there because i'm
planning on going to medical school
on the near future and that's going to
be probably 200 to 300 thousand dollars
so my question is what can i do today to
minimize the effect on my financial
future
that's a really good question well what
you did
whether you did it on purpose or said it
out loud or not
to get where you are was you said okay
here's what school costs
the particular school that you are in
what are you at uh
florida or where are you yeah florida
okay so you're so i'm gonna go to
florida and here's what florida costs
and here's what the books cost and
here's how much money mom and dad can
put in
and here's how much i can work and you
said okay here's
here's a target and it's a target that i
can hit and here's the steps it takes to
hit that target right
that's what you did i don't know how
intentional or how out loud you or
whether you had spreadsheets or whether
you just did it in your head or
how you did it but the end of the day in
order to accomplish graduating from the
university of florida
100 debt free that is not an accidental
act
you did intentional steps agreed
yes okay let's do the same thing with
med school
number one med school uh is
unbelievably there is an
unbelievably wide spectrum of cost based
on where you go
so 300 000 one place maybe 150 another
place
where you live on campus where you live
off campus whether you're
what city are you in how expensive is
that city
a lot of variables that go into the cost
here and it's not like there's only one
price for med school and it's always 300
grand that is not true
follow me just like there's always
there's more than one
price for a four-year degree when you
live in the state of florida
uh i mean you chose the university of
florida
and um uh fine choice
uh but but i mean you could have chosen
to go to vanderbilt
here in nashville and paid eight times
more than you paid
for the same four-year degree by the way
correct okay you didn't do that so
that's my point we're going to choose
something that's more affordable since
we're broke
uh because i got to tell you i've gone
to a lot of doctors and i never once
asked where they went to school i just
said can you fix this
right yeah and that's all i want to know
can you fix this and they go well i
can't but i know a guy that went to
so-and-so and he went to this school and
he can fix it okay good well let's go
over there but i don't start the
conversation with doctors and lawyers on
where you went to school
and i've hired a bunch of them over the
years i'm old i've had both lawyers and
doctors in my life god help me
but um so that's the thing right so
the point is there's very little value
on where you go to school
unless you're going into a very
specialized type of medicine
or you're going into some kind of
research or you're going into something
where the prestige crap
matters what really matters is can you
learn to fix humans
and be a doc and that's the thing so i'm
going to go shopping if i'm you and i'm
going to become an
expert on every med school in the u.s
and what they cost
and then i'm going to target in on the
bottom 5 or 10 percent of those
and do that that's thing one thing two
is i'm going to investigate the
medical industry the hospital
corporations that are out there
that desperately want young docs and try
to find out what programs they have got
where they're willing to pay for you to
become a doc
oh but you promised to work there for a
few years for them after you get out
that'll do it number two military has
the same exact program
they'll pay for you to be a doc and then
you work for the military for a few
years
after you get out and it's a very set
specific
program you know what you're signing up
for and it's way the crap cheaper
than 350 000 in student loan debt okay
number four there's a thing called an md
phd
program very hard to get into but if
your grades are great
and you're an excellent citizen you
stand a chance people do actually get in
them i talked to a guy last week
in the md phd program what this is is
you actually go to work for the
university teaching classes at the
university while you're in med school
as an employee of the university a very
special employee of the university
you go to med school free
now that's the sweetest deal i gave you
on the list but very hard to get into
there's not a whole bunch of those out
there there's not a whole bunch of
candidates that are accepted
but dude if you can land one of those
that's the gold standard right there on
med school for free
and it will change your career
if you can go to med school debt-free
because you'll
make different choices about the type of
medicine you study
you'll make different choices on who you
go to work for you'll make different
choices on the crap you have to put up
with all these companies
in order to eat and pay your bills and i
just
i don't want you all tied up in that
stuff i think you're too smart
so uh point being is it easy to go to
med school debt-free absolutely not it's
not easy to go
university of florida debt-free but you
did it all your friends are lazing
around the dorm
getting a degree in beer pong and they
got forty five thousand dollars in
student loan debt
and they're just happy to be a gator you
know i mean that's it
come on seriously this is the problem
isn't it
but all you did was you got focused and
intentional and you turned it around
and you you said i'm gonna be different
and i want you to do the exact same
paradigm the exact same mindset for this
hold on
i'll have kelly pick up i'm going to
give you a copy of anthony o'neil's book
debt
free degree it's really designed for
undergraduates coming out
our high school graduates coming out
going into undergrad teaching
people to do how to do what you just did
but
there's also some good thoughts and some
good promises in there
things to follow through on like i just
gave you on how to do even
grad school work debt-free without
getting all tied up in it
so hey thank you for calling in brother
guys the student loan
problem is not an education
problem
it's not an education problem no one can
afford to get an education in america
today
just not true that's not a true
statement
you can go to an in-state school
live in your parents house eat your
mama's food
come home at lunch and have a baloney
sandwich go back to class
[Music]
and pay in-state tuition and work a job
and you can work your way through just
like he did with a little help from mom
and dad and you can get an undergraduate
degree
in america today with zero student loan
debt
but the first thing that has to happen
is you have to stop assuming
the student loan debt is the only way to
get a degree
so get up off your assumes and go do
something about this
this is the dave ramsey show